although
although i changed my thinking
the hood did not come out of me no oh
no it probably never will it actually
came
a lot it came into ping pong a lot
so i would be so i got into a lot of
altercations
oh [ __ ] and ping pong yeah peop
people know me dude i saw i saw a video
of you uh playing some
some guy it was like a tournament or
whatever and like
at the end of the round he just
basically like tossed the ball over with
like you weren't ready for it and you're
like are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you gonna count that [ __ ] oh man yes
so that that's actually recent that
oh is it really yeah that's not that
long that's i mean when i say reason
that's probably like four or five years
ago
okay that i know what that is i remember
exactly that
was uh me playing against chinese
national team
so i was playing against chinese
national team and and the umpire
and the umpire was being a dick like
really like
i actually won that point and he said i
did it and if you look at the camera
i served the ball and then and he went
past him and he said
that that i lost the point and i just
flipped out and i got angry
and and yeah yeah so but then he also
like nonchalantly like tossed the ball
yeah yeah yeah and i i
smashed it up into the air yeah yeah i
got a lot you know what's funny that
video
i got a lot of haters from that video oh
yeah
oh i don't know why this guy represents
america he's such a bad
he's such a bad uh uh uh uh influence on
people blah blah and i'm like yo you
guys are idiots man
first of all yeah they don't know they
don't know know what happened and
there's more to that video that
[ __ ] cheated dude exactly
yo and there's more to that video too
they they also
um made a mistake and they gave
me a point that they should have gave to
him oh really the chinese guy and i said
no that's not the score and he said
no it's the score i said no it's not the
score and they say it is the score and i
went
i took the guy's hands off the thing and
changed the score myself
and the crowd started clapping well
that's crazy yeah yeah
i bet a lot i mean i don't know but i'm
sure they're
in the sport of ping pong a lot of
people from china aren't used to like
raising their voice and sticking up for
themselves you know they're very like
soft-spoken no i i tell you
another funny story about that so once i
started playing pro
um my first competition
was i had three was it let me see the
changing g1
yeah okay so the first the first
competition pro competition i played was
in germany
right german or german open and i got
smoked
destroyed by people that i actually
played with got smoked i was so nervous
then the next week i was in
in uh holland in in rotterdam
so i remember exactly i played the first
person i played was
from russia got smoked smoked no chance
second person i played was from england
got smoked
no chess the third person i played was
from china
right and uh i was playing this chinese
kid and i remember
i would never forget his name his name
is chen jun ji i can never forget this
name because chen jung
this moment is actually what defined me
in table tennis was
this particular moment here so i played
this i'm playing this chinese kid
he's smoking me first game i think was
11-1
second game 11-2 i don't even i was
getting killed i was getting killed
right then um my friend
uh my german friend when i told you
about we were always together so
whenever i travel we're always together
i'm always with this dude
and uh i was teaching him some hood
stuff
right because he's very very german
proper germany and i was like nah man
you gotta go boop boop boop you know no
you gotta say yo what's up man yeah so
i i i i taught him a lot of hood stuff
like
right so um when i'm playing this dude
it was
three zero change guys three zero right
uh he my my friend he's coaching me
close timeout and he says come on wally
he said [ __ ] like this right and so so i
said okay you know
he wants me to get pumped up right right
trying to get you fired up i made a
serve
and it aced the chinese guy right and
when he aced him
i was like yeah baby that's it
yo the dude almost [ __ ] bad bad
is this on video no i wish i had this on
video i
wish i had it on video yo the dude but i
still have the article i still
i think i still have the article that
they wrote about this
so that dude just because he's never
seen that nobody's ever seen that
as a matter of fact nobody didn't even
know who i was nobody's never seen this
i started bringing the gangster into
ping-pong i started getting real gangsta
with it real gangster
wow then i took a game off him which is
it's it doesn't even make sense
like it's it's almost like some junior
high school kid
freaking taking a game off lebron in
basketball some junior high school kid
like no chance it's negative i took a
game off this dude right
then we played again right actually he
was up 2-0
then then we played again he won he won
the next game very close
then that was uh a three three one it's
four out of seven
i won the next game so i won the fifth
game which is
crazy and everybody's looking at because
now i'm really pumped i'm like that's it
baby
take them down take them down this boy's
got no chance i'm talking magic you're
probably psyching him the [ __ ] out no
had him psyched out like crazy you were
[ __ ] his head then
it was three two nine so so at this time
the the scores go to eleven i mean
eleven points so
three two nine six for me
so i just need one more i need one more
one more
game and it's 3-3 against chinese
national team the best in the world
right so three two nine six and and i'm
making noise this dude's [ __ ] in his
pants the whole time he's like scared to
death
because no one's never seen anyone be
gangsta with it right right
ping pong is more like yeah
that's it that's it nobody gets crazy i
was getting crazy come on baby
like it was almost like i was playing
football basketball i don't know if
that's what they're doing
and uh it was nine six and then um
the the stupid thing i did was believe
that i could win
and that's where you get screwed up
so i what do you mean the stupid thing
you did was believe that you could win
tell you because i started to believe
i could win i said okay let me come down
and finish this match
it was the wrong freaking thing to do i
should have just kept being crazy and
kept being me and maybe i maybe i would
have beat him
but because i calmed down because i
really believed i could win when i
really had no chance to beat this dude
but i started to believe i could win
then i calmed down
and i started to try to focus and then
the guy came back and won the match
right and uh and before there's one part
i forgot to say
um so when i made the score when the
score was nine so what happened was the
score was nine
six three two for him and the coach
called the timeout at nine six because
if i win this game it's three three
i think this dude's gonna be more
nervous in the last game the coach
change coach called timeout and chance
could start
yelling at him right and my german
friend speaks chinese
and and and what the coach was saying
was like i never saw this guy
anywhere in my life because nobody knew
me i never saw this guy
if you lose to this guy you would never
play this country again
oh my god oh god but it's real china is
not messing around oh no if you lose to
me
that's it yeah your career is finished
and [ __ ] and the guy came back
and i lost eleven nine and it was
another point
but also i calmed down and i thought i
could win when i really couldn't and
i lost but well is it the fact that you
thought you could win i mean i i think
it might have been the fact that you
were maybe overthinking it
well more that i wasn't giving him the
respect
that he should get right because that's
the thing you shouldn't give him
his respect then you're gonna you yeah
you shouldn't right
but once you started to but once you
start to give him the respect
you know because now i'm saying okay i
can beat this guy
that's that's before i didn't care right
now i'm saying i can beat this guy okay
focus
focus you can win this match and i
changed what i was doing yeah that was
working
and then i lost and uh but that was the
start
of everyone in the world knowing who i
was
every top player in the world knew this
crazy guy from new york city who's
yelling all over the place
and everyone knew me and and they wrote
an article about
what's more important skill or mental
right because i was beating them in the
mental in the mental studies this guy
obviously had the skill
oh yeah i had no chance zero chance zero
chance but
mentally i got him so yeah and then i
started to notice that like
the kind of character that i had was
very interesting
for media in the sport because they
never seen a sport they see the
hip-hop guy play ping-pong so i started
getting all these interviews
and and and i would lose and they would
interview me and not the winner
and it was crazy i was like whoa what's
going on to the point where
where sometimes they started giving me
too many matches on the tv table
and i i i remember one time in china i
complained about it i said hey
can you not put me on the tv table like
like
what's the tv table so so for example
let's let's say in a pro tour
a proto can have anywhere from like
eight to 12 tables
right but not every table has a tv
camera so usually two tables will have
table one and table two
will always have that tv camera there
all the other matches won't may not have
a tv camera
they they may have they they may be
filmed
but it wouldn't stream to tv only these
two tables
so a lot of players they want to be on
the tv table
i never wanted to be on the tv table i
really hated the tv table because
i'm probably one of the worst players in
the pro tour why do i when i want to be
on a tv table
i want to be in like the table that's
like in the corner
you know away i don't think people
wanted to see you yes
so so the the the i remember one time i
was in china
and and and i had two matches on the tv
today which is crazy
pros that probably don't even get too
much on the tv and this is in
preliminary rounds
it's not even the main draw and i told
myself listen
i just played on the tv table can you
please take my next match
off the tv table and and this is
something that every
player wants every player wants to be on
the tv table
i didn't want it and i told my skin and
then the chinese guy goes
no wally no you are
good for tv i was like what
i say yo getting killed on tv is not
good for me
it's like no it's okay yeah so
and then i realized like yo people
people they they don't care about your
skill level
you know i brought something different i
brought this coolness you know
i bought this this hip-hop style and and
and and you know this this this
craziness to the sport
you were fascinating to them
you